They wanted him to provide them
with a miracle that would
be according to what they
wanted, what they requested. A
miracle upon request And they
came with all kinds of fanciful
requests. We mentioned that it
is not a condition. Nor is it
even appropriate. That the
prophets and messengers come to
their people and provide
miracles based on what their
what agonist desire of them.
This is not something which is
the purpose of a miracle. The
purpose of the miracles of the
prophets and messengers and the
signs of their prophethood is
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
named their miracles as not He
named them as Ayat. Ayat. He
referred to the miracles of the
prophets as evidences signs and
that is really gets to the core
of what the purpose of these
miracles are. It's supposed to
be a sign, an evidence that is
beyond any doubt. Beyond any
reasonable doubt. That
This is in fact a prophet from
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. This
is the purpose of these
evidences, of these signs,
these miracles. And the prophet
was sent with a plethora of
miracles. As was mentioned by
and others Of the scholars of
the Muslim that the prophet
miracles were more than a
thousand. If we were to really
go through all of the miracles
found in the Quran, mentioned
in the Quran, mentioned in the
sunnah, there are more than a
thousand.
So, it's not as if he didn't
provide any evidence for his
prophethood. This was provided
abundantly. Rather what it is
is that they wanted it to be
according to their choosing,
according to their request.
However, the people that
requested specific miracles
from their messengers never
believed. They would not
believe because they had
already predetermined and
decided that they would not
believe no matter what this
prophet or messenger showed
them or brought to them. It was
an issue of arrogance and an
issue of antagonism. Not an
issue of doubt. They may
express doubt. They may say we
doubt this but in their heart
of hearts, they do not doubt.
And noone can doubt after
having met with a prophet or a
messenger and seen the miracles
and seen thee. Seeing thee,
substance of this prophet or
messengers, religion would
doubt. This doubt is is
unfounded. illogical However,
it's an issue of antagonism. We
want to come up with any reason
where we can exonerate
ourselves from the shame of
rejecting a messenger of god.
and so they come with these
fanciful requests and the
prophet and the prophets and
messengers are not in any way
obligated to honor these
requests. Because they are not
part of the message.
So, they say, if he is truly a
messenger, why doesn't he
provide us with miracles like
the miracles of the prophets
that preceded him? The scholars
mention in reviewing and
researching
prophet life and legacy
mentioned, they mentioned that
There has never been sent a
messenger or prophet except
that our prophet Muhammad
has been given similar or
superior miracles to that
prophet or messenger. As an
instance of this, Musa Alaihi
Salam, one of his miracles was
that the sea parted and the
miracle of the prophet is that
the moon was parted.
It's mentioned as well in the
Quran that
was able to was able by the
will of Allah.
you have the dead speak
and this happened after the
prophet
with in the time of the
companions.
Ibrahim Alaihi Salam One of his
miracles was that he was thrown
in the fire and not burned. and
this happened with one of the
one of the in the time of the
companions, in the time of
Omar. Abu Idris The great
Muhadith of Dimashk. And the
Taberine, was in his home
sleeping and his entire house
burned down around him.
Everything, and he was left
unscathed. And subsequently,
Omar Radi Allah demanded to
meet.
after this incident, etcetera,
etcetera. Anything that is
considered miraculous for his
is part of his miracles as
well.
but the issue here is not just
that We have an overwhelming
body of evidence supporting the
validity of the prophet
message. The issue is as Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says, No
people, not a single town that
we have destroyed, has preceded
except that they as well ask
for a sign, a miracle according
to their discretion, and when
it came to them, they rejected
it and refused it. So, if that
is the case and that is the
pattern of history, shall we
expect these individuals to
believe, and to break that
pattern obviously, the answer
is no. Highly unlikely, if not
impossible. While Allah
him,
Allah
[Silence]
Why would you follow a man just
yourselves? He should have
been an angel. He should have
been this. He should have been
that. He should have been from
another country. He should have
spoken another language. All of
these silly things that they
came up with. And so Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala addresses
this and he says That which
translates to and we have never
sent
before you accept, meaning as
messengers or prophet, except
men whom we send revelation to.
So, then, ask the people of
knowledge before you, if you do
not know. So, here, we have a
couple of things. Number one,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions that he has always
sent men. and that is the
One of the conditions of
prophethood All of the prophets
have conditions, unanimous
conditions, unanimous criteria
that they meet. Number one,
they are all human beings. They
are not from the Jin. And that
goes back to the nature of the
that they are. That they are
obscure from us as humans, but
we are not obscure from the and
so it would stand to reason
that messengers and prophets
from the time of Adam until the
time of Muhammad would all be
from a people that everyone
could observe and see and have
access to.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions that he place
prophethood and he placed the
book and the revelation in the
offspring and the lineage of
Noor and Ibrahim. And there is
no jin from their lineage.
Number two, that they are male
It must be male There are no
female prophets. There are no
female messengers. and that is
clear with regards to in
reading the Quran and that is
the correct opinion. Very very
few scholars throughout history
have ever viewed that a woman
may be a prophet or a
messenger. a prophet such as
Mariam Alaihi Salam or Umusa
These were not prophets. They
were merely righteous women.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
about Isa and his mother Mariam
and if anybody in the whole
Quran of the women mentioned is
more likely to be a prophet, it
would be Mariam Alaihi Salam.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
[Silence]
high-ranking in righteousness.
If she was more than that, he
would've he would've mentioned
that she's a prophet or that
she's a messenger.
Likewise, another condition of
prophethood is that The prophet
be emancipated, not be a slave
own owned by another person
because this would limit this
prophet's ability to spread and
propagate the message of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. So, when a
prophet is sent, they are sent
as free.
Another condition to
prophethood is morality.
trustworthiness They cannot be
immoral, untrustworthy,
deceitful not before
prophethood and not after
certainly.
Likewise, general morality
That is protected by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala which is
referred to as Al Isma. Al Isma
means that they are protected
and prevented by Allah. From
committing major sins.
from consistently committing
minor sins committing minor
sins that are obscene or
perverse in nature.
and whether they can may is it
possible for one of them to
commit a minor sin not
continuously, and not a minor
sin that is perverse in nature,
or not? This is a difference of
opinion amongst the scholars of
Islam. After agreeing on all of
the previously mentioned
things. And so all of the
prophets and messengers who
preceded the prophet Muhammad
they were of this caliber and
they had these descriptions.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then
says, ask then the people of
knowledge if you do not know.
This is a reference to the
people of the book.
predominantly the Jews because
they are more of a people of
knowledge
and so this is a challenge to
trace the lineage of the
prophets and messengers in the
previous revelations of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. and two,
compare the prophet Muhammad in
those descriptions. And does he
fit that criteria? Is he unique
in any of those senses? The
answer is no and you will find
a solid, connected interwoven,
chain of prophethood from the
time of Noah Alaihi Salam to
the time of the prophet
[Arabic recitation]